come on down to the grand reopening the
swell
I'll be there I best friend Tim
Heidecker will be there you're like what
you see hmm you're gonna like the fake
trees you're gonna like all our new
store oh you're gonna like meeting my
new son Jeffrey I'm gonna murder myself
if you don't come down to my new [ __ ]
mall come on down to the grand reopening
the swallow Valley Mall my dad told me
this is the coolest mall ever you think
you know more than my dad don't [ __ ]
come it's a grand reopening of the
swallow Valley Mall it's just off route
35 right here in historic swallow Valley
in 2012 I didn't mean to tell you this
all night i love you man I love our
friendship thank you i honor you and I
honor a friendship I honor our look two
of America's most celebrated icons hi
I'm Eric Wareheim and I'm Tim Heidecker
[ __ ] to an error oh yeah
presents a motion picture so epic I want
to eat it [ __ ] heart it will leave
you in shock
breathe it's got romance i want to go
deep inside you and exploding your canal
it's got at you where are your sons it's
got sex
it's got special effects
it's got stars
hi hi it's got shrimp clearly quit the
shrimp bhutia lo kuda sure sounds like
shrimp
Oh laughs tim and eric's billion dollar
movie that's it that's their movie i
paid a billion dollars for that piece of
[ __ ] oh yeah